in zukunft verpflichtend getestet werden
soll das sagen menschen aus erfurt die
wir heute mittag befragt haben viele
machen sich sorgen weil die
infektionszahlen steigen und genau darum
soll es jetzt gehen in diesem zdf
spezial ganz herzlich willkommen die
serie notruf hafenkante verschiebt sich
um circa zehn minuten noch sind alle
großen bundesländer in velen modus die
meisten schulen sind geschlossen viele
familien verreist und doch steigen in
deutschland die infektionszahlen stetig
an
eine maßnahme einen weiteren anstieg zu
verhindern wurde heute beschlossen die
testpflicht für rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten
sie gilt ab samstag und dann auch für
viele urlauber bendit berichtet das
sieht aus wie ein weiteres terminal am
frankfurter flughafen aber hierher
kommen nur passagiere gerade gelandet
sind zurück kommen vom urlaub aus einem
corona risikogebiet
persönliche daten aufnehmen und dann
anstehen für den abstrich in einem der
test räume familie winkel blech ramisch
ist frisch zurück aus bosnien nimmt die
warterei in kauf
und man ist es auch verpflichten
ich habe mein kleinkind ist auch
gegenüber den anderen welt bis zu
zweitausend passagiere aus
risikogebieten testen sie hier pro tag
noch gilt entweder test oder zwei wochen
quarantäne daheim
ich habe
viele geschwister ich habe zwei kleine
schwester vom großen bruder und ich habe
eine oma daheim und besonders bei ihr
ist es wichtig dass ich kein corona mit
nach hause bringe samstag könnten die
schlangen hier noch länger werden dann
gilt eine testpflicht für urlauber aus
risikogebieten völlig offen allerdings
wie die durchgesetzt werden soll
inwiefern bei verpflichtenden tests die
leute dann eben in dieses zentrum
geleitet werden und wie das umgesetzt
werden kann ist eine polizeiliche
aufgabe die dann entsprechend reduziert
werden muss am zentralen busbahnhof
berlin-charlottenburg kommen sie aus
serbien nord mazedonien bosnien zurück
länder die das robert koch institut als
risikogebiete einstuft simone reuter hat
ihren sohn abgeholt der mit papa im
kosovo war risikogebiet stabil sie ihn
lieber gleich testen lassen im zelt
nebenan die prozedur ein wenig
unangenehm in spätestens 48 stunden soll
das ergebnis da sein
höchste zeit dass ab samstag solche
tests verpflichtend sind findet die
mutter als ich es besser wenn es pflicht
ist weil ich denke dass es für alle
besser wenn eben die meisten getestet
sind und dann man weiß bleibt man zu
hause oder kann man rausgehen halt bis
samstag sollen überall in deutschland
weitere tests zentren entstehen etwa an
bahnhöfen in gesundheitsämtern oder
arztpraxen im studio bei uns begrüße ich
jetzt den ministerpräsidenten vor einem
103 schön gedacht es gibt eine pflicht
jetzt sich testen zu lassen wenn man aus
einem risikogebiet kommt ab samstag
es wird aber nicht wirklich kontrolliert
und nachverfolgt wie kann das
funktionieren
na ja wir sind ja dabei den
bundesländern wirklich teststationen
aufzubauen und wir appellieren wirklich
dann auch an den verstand der menschen
man muss ja sagen die bevölkerung in
deutschland ist er insgesamt wirklich
sehr vernünftig im umgang mit den
anforderungen und klar ist auch wer
dagegen verstößt macht sich tatsächlich
dann auch ja dann können wir das ahnten
sozusagen als ordnungswidrigkeit und
auch mit einem bußgeld verhängen wenn
jetzt mehr getestet wird auch die zahlen
wieder ansteigen heißt das ja auch für
die gesundheitsämter für die
hausarztpraxen eine große belastung
jetzt arbeiten die aber seit monaten
schon wirklich am limit
wie soll das gehen ja ich denke es ist
wichtig was wir tun und allenfalls
beispielsweise wir haben keine großen
flughäfen aber wir haben beispielsweise
an den autobahnen zu unseren
außengrenzen belgien frankreich
luxemburg haben wir zusätzliche test
stationen aufgebaut dort leiten und
lenken wir dann die bürger und
bürgerinnen henley daneben aus
unterschiedlichen gebieten kommen und
unterstützen mit dieser infrastruktur
das ganz normale medizinisches system
und ich glaube dass auch wirklich
wichtig jetzt die urlaubsrückkehrer bald
auch nach und nach werden die schulen
wieder geöffnet viele menschen sind es
auch leid die maske zu tragen wollen
nicht mehr wird es bald doch schärfere
maßnahmen dann geben müssen wenn es so
weitergeht das wird ganz und gar an uns
liegen denn die menschen haben ganz
bestimmte dinge gelernt zum beispiel
abstand zu halten auch maske zu tragen
in bestimmten situationen und das ist
auch in zukunft unbedingt notwendig das
hat ja deutschland wirklich auch stark
gemacht dass wir das gemeinsam
hinbekommen haben und es wird gerade in
zukunft ganz besonders wichtig seien ihr
die tests sind eine momentaufnahme nicht
mehr und nicht weniger
sie sind wichtig war ganz viele menschen
aus gebieten kommen wo wir andere
infektionsraten haben aber danach müssen
wir wirklich auch sagen wir haben jetzt
nicht nur negativ test in der tasche
sondern wir müssen diese regeln
einhalten um das mit zu vermeiden dass
es eine zweite welle gibt und da können
wir alle etwas dafür tun wird dass in
zukunft dann eher regionale
beschränkungen lockdown geben oder wie
stellen sie sich das vor wenn sich die
lage dann einzeln wieder zuspitzt ja so
ist ja die regelung auch bundesweit und
es ist denke ich ein sehr vernünftiges
vorgehen denn im moment ist es so dass
wir tatsächlich das virus trotzdem unter
kontrolle haben wir kennen die ausbrüche
wir können sie lokalisieren wir können
nachgehen und es macht nur sinn
tatsächlich dann auch direkt regionale
konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen zum
beispiel im grösseren umfeld zu testen
oder in quarantäne die menschen zu
schicken und das ist ein sehr sinnvolles
vorgehen in deutschland es ist auch
erfolgreich und so wird jetzt erstmal
die zukunft auch aussehen wenn alle
mitmachen dann schaffen wir das auch gut
sagt die ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland pfalz malu dreyer vielen dank
denen die einen sprechen von der zweiten
welle anderem einen der begriff
dauerwelle sei treffender
fakt ist die pandemie ist da immer noch
und sie ist immer noch eine bedrohung
für unsere gesundheit und das soziale
und das wirtschaftliche leben in unserem
mein kollege kollege achim flora schaut
auf die entwicklungen der zahlen und
zeigt wo wir jetzt gerade stehen
1045 die zahl die heute besorgnis
auslöst 1045 neue infektionen an einem
tag der höchste wert seit zwei monaten
wir alle wissen wir alle sehen die
pandemie ist noch da und sie geht weiter
aber nach all den wochen und monaten
setzt bei manchen eine gewisse ermüdung
und es gibt das trügerische gefühl so
schlimm war das doch bislang gar nicht
und so scheint es dass die zeit über
weitere lockerungen nachzudenken erst
einmal vorbei ist jetzt fürchten viele
die zweite welle nach der ersten sanken
die infektionszahlen schnell auf
niedriges niveau die hoffnung das virus
im griff zu haben war da doch nun
steigen die fallzahlen die der
kontinuierlich sorge macht da vor allem
die zunehmende sorglosigkeit vieler was
wir sehen sind viele kleinere ausbrüche
menschen stecken sich an bei
familienfeiern am arbeitsplatz oder in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen seit dem
massenausbruch beim fleischverarbeiter
tennis mit rund 1400 infizierten häufen
sich die meldungen über diese kleineren
ausbrüchen zu letzt offenbach knapp 50
infektionen durch reiserückkehrer die
stadt macht nun ernst maßnahmen
verschärft die masken pflicht wird
rigoros durchgesetzt 50 euro bußgeld bei
verstoß ohne vorwarnung die polizei
kontrolliert schafft was wir hier sehen
sind zwei mal nicht ordnungsgemäße
tragen von masken
das ist ein paar zahlen bestand der
kostet 50 euro
maske ist immer die zeiten des kuschel
kurses ein bisschen vorbei wir werden
jetzt den leuten ans portemonnaie gehen
neben zu sagen ist 50 euro bußgeld dies
darauf gibt sie heben werde nach
möglichkeit in bar damit es eben im
portemonnaie
ähnliches wird man demnächst auch in
bayern und nordrhein-westfalen erleben
bußgelder sind auch dort beschlossene
sache um jeden preis soll eine zweite
welle verhindert werden und das so lange
bis ein impfstoff verfügbar sein wird
bei uns in der sendung begrüße ich jetzt
frau professorin ulrike protzer
direktorin des instituts für virologie
an der tu münchen guten abend guten
abend wie muss man dann die neuesten
zahlen jetzt einordnen es wird mehr
getestet und so gibt es auch mehr
positive fälle wie sehr spitzt sich die
lage dann wirklich zu also wir sehen
schon einem leichten anstieg der fälle
wohingegen das test niveau in den
letzten sieben acht wochen relativ
konstant geblieben ist also dadurch kann
man es eigentlich nicht erklären
aber das ist uns ja moderater anstieg
ich glaube man muss da auch die kirche
im dorf lassen
welchen effekt versprechen sie sich
jetzt von den pflicht test sie ab
samstag gelten wie verlässlich finden
sie die umsetzung und die regelung also
ich glaube diese pflicht tests machen
schon sinn sie sind ein baustein in der
kontrolle des virus aber wir können
dieses virus nicht weg testen das heißt
das testen alleine wird es nicht machen
sondern es gilt weiterhin die
hygienemaßnahmen beachten und in
quarantäne gehen in dem moment in dem
man risiko kontakt da war denn ein test
allein hilft da nicht ganz sicher zu
sein
aber muss man nicht auch stärker
kontrollieren
wer sich wirklich testen lässt wer auf
solch einem risikogebiet kommt
ich weiß nicht ob man da alles
kontrollieren muss er den zwang gehen
muss ich glaube wir haben ja doch eine
sehr verantwortungsvolle bevölkerung die
hat gezeigt dass sie da wirklich
mitarbeitet und ich denke dass man das
ohne auf einer basis lassen kann wo man
sagt es ist verpflichtend geht da bitte
hin aber mehr braucht's glaube ich nicht
die zahlen sind angestiegen die schulen
öffnen nach und nach und die ferien
gehen zu ende
mit welchen szenarien rechnen sie in den
nächsten wochen ich bin mir relativ
sicher ich glaube da muss man kein
wahrsager sein dass die zahlen an
erkältungskrankheiten jetzt im herbst
wieder an stärke im moment noch nicht
das wetter ist noch so schön es ist
sonnig aber wenn es mal gegen oktober
wird werden wir sicherlich mehr
atemwegsinfekte haben und werden dann
beschäftigt sein herauszubekommen was
ist in ein corona virus und was ist was
anderes was vielleicht jetzt nicht
gefährlich ist
roboter vielen dank das gespräch haben
wir kurz vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
der appell ist deutlich geworden neben
verordnungen und regen sind am ende ein
sicht und umsicht entscheidend zum
schutz unserer gesundheit und um weitere
restriktionen zu verhindern
in dieser zeit helfen informationen und
fakten die sie jederzeit auch zf heute
bekommen als es aber auch in unseren
angeboten in den sozialen netzwerken
das war unser zdf spezial notruf
hafenkante folgt jetzt ich wünsche ihnen
alles gute und einen schönen abend noch
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]